Speaker 1: All right, well, we have a very,
very big news.
Another one of these Trumpist election, Clark
official type people, has has been indicted.
I'm talking here about Tina Peters.
We've spoken about Tina Peters before county
clerk who embrace the Big Lie is indicted
months after an election data leak.
This this really is a delightful story.
Talking Points Memo reads Tina Peters, the
Republican clerk of Mesa County, Colorado,
who was long suspected of aiding a leak of
sensitive election machinery.
Data from her own office has been indicted
on multiple counts by a Colorado grand jury,
as has her deputy Belinda Knisley, or nicely.
According to the indictment.
Peters and nicely allegedly devised and executed
a scheme to breach security protocols that
led to the distribution of confidential information
from county election systems guys.
The calls are coming from inside the house
to carry out the scheme, the indictment alleged
Peters committed to criminal impersonation
against the Colorado man, whose name was used
for an access badge for a county election
offices.
The charges against Peters.
This is just delightful.
The charges against Peters include three counts
of attempting to influence a public servant,
one count of conspiracy to commit attempt
to influence a public servant.
Weird, weird language, but I think that's
the way the law is written.
Criminal impersonation, conspiracy to commit
criminal impersonation, identity theft, first
degree official misconduct, violation of duty
and failing to comply with the Secretary of
State.
This guy, this is what they say Democrats
do to steal elections.
There's another article from Ars Technica
Republican county clerk indicted in voting
machine breach arrest warrant issued.
Tina Peters indicted on 10 counts for quote
deceptive scheme to leak confidential data.
This was long overdue.
Tina Peters showed up.
You know those pillow fests.
Mike Mike Lindell from MyPillow.
He was a big supporter of Tina Peters.
And this is way overdue.
There is a clip which we previously looked
at on a live stream in which she was arrested
in public.
It's just so delightful to see it.
And here are officers taking her into custody.
She's screaming, Oh no.
Unidentified: Let go of me.
Speaker 1: Let go, let me.
And now she's starting to kick like a like
a threatened horse.
Unidentified: I just can't give me my key
to my car.
Speaker 1: Give me my keys, my car.
All right.
So she was publicly taken into custody.
It was just fantastic.
And by the way, she's running for secretary
of State of Colorado, and she had the audacity
to put out this video yesterday in the midst
of everything that's going on.
Speaker 6: Hi, I'm Tina Peters.
I'm currently the clerk of Mesa County, and
I've announced that I'm running for the Office
of Secretary of State in Colorado.
Since then, I've been crisscrossing Colorado,
speaking to various civic groups, including
Republican Lincoln Day Dinners, and I've been
so honored by the overwhelming response.
I'm running for Colorado Secretary of State.
Speaker 1: Is it wrong that I take pleasure
in this horrible woman going down?
And, you know, I'm not one to celebrate bad
things happening to people.
But she's accused of doing not only really
bad things, but she was part of spreading
the big lie that everybody on the left was
meddling with elections.
It was Democrats, it was Joe Biden.
It was whoever.
She was involved in a conspiracy scheme, per
the charges related to elections in her role
as the county clerk.
I'm sorry, guys.
I'm taking pleasure.
I'm taking pleasure
Speaker 6: to restore trust and put an end.
Can you imagine overreach in our election
process trust?
We need to get back to honoring our Colorado
Constitution, honoring our state legislature,
to craft laws through a representative government
by of and for the people.
Speaker 1: Yeah, she's been arrested.
She has now been arrested, taken into custody.
And it's all absolutely fantastic.
Law and order, guys.
Law and order.
That's the important thing.